pasamos a ver las cifras y la economía
de los temas destacados de la jornada no
los cuenta jorge hurtado jorge muy
buenas noches comenzamos en argentina
porque los precios de los consumidores
dieron un nuevo salto histórico en este
país argentina sin techo definitivamente
así y bueno dos datos que son bastante
históricos la inflación se aceleró ahí
en julio hasta el 7,4 por ciento
respecto a junio hablamos de la
inflación interanual y alcanzó el nivel
más alto desde el año 2002 por tanto en
los últimos 12 meses acumuló un
incremento del 71 por ciento este otro
dato el dato anual es el más alto en
tres décadas según informó el instituto
nacional de estadísticas y censos la
división con mayor aumento del mes fue
recreación y cultura en parte por los
aumentos de los servicios asociados al
turismo durante este receso invernal
equipamiento y mantenimiento del hogar
así como restaurantes y hoteles ocuparon
los siguientes puestos en este ranking
la magnitud del salto del 7,4 por ciento
registrado en julio es la mayor subida
desde abril del año 2002 cuando la
inflación se disparó tras el estallido a
finales del año 2001 de una severa
crisis política económica y social en
argentina la fuerte aceleración de esta
inflación en julio se produce en un
contexto de sobresaltos políticos con la
renuncia primero de martín guzmán como
ministro de economía y su sustitución
por silvina batakis tres semanas después
el reemplazo de batakis por sergio massa
al frente de la cartera económica jorge
seguimos en argentina porque atención a
la cifra un millón de niños en ese país
evitan una comida al día porque no
tienen dinero para adquirirla según
cifras de unicef que dicen allí bueno
esto es una situación que también está
afectando a 3 millones de adultos según
una nueva encuesta publicada por ese
organismo la inestabilidad laboral y la
insuficiencia en los ingresos de los
deudores con niños y niñas son los
principales determinantes de esta
problemática de acuerdo con la encuesta
rápida sobre la situación de la niñez y
adolescencia de 2022 de unicef el
organismo afirma que la insuficiencia en
los ingresos también generó una
reducción del 67 por ciento en el
consumo de carne y del 40% en la ingesta
de frutas verduras y lácteos esta
encuesta también dice que el 36 por
ciento de los hogares con menores dejó
de comprar alguna por no tener dinero
afectando a más de un millón de niños
niñas y adolescentes en argentina en ese
país uno de cada tres hogares no puede
cubrir sus gastos corrientes
hablamos ahora de méxico porque el banco
central aumentó los tipos de interés de
referencia en ese país el emisor subió
su tasa de interés de referencia en tres
cuartos de punto porcentual hasta un
récord de 85 por ciento reflejando la
decisión de política más reciente de la
reserva federal de eeuu recordemos que
eeuu el principal socio comercial de
méxico- los cinco miembros de la junta
directiva de ban 5 como se conoce al
banco central votaron por unanimidad a
favor de la segunda subida de 75 puntos
básicos pero advirtieron de que van a
evaluar cómo evolucionan y los precios
van 5 también ha aumentado los tipos en
un total de 450 puntos básicos en sus
últimas diez reuniones de política
monetaria la inflación anual en la
segunda economía de américa latina subió
al 8,15 por ciento en julio es un nivel
más alto en casi 22 años porque seguimos
en méxico porque oiga una buena noticia
para esta sección económica
día de turismo aseguró que los ingresos
de turismo en ese país ya superaron los
niveles pre pandemia qué bueno para los
mexicanos los datos dicen que dejó los
turistas dejaron una derrama económica
de 13 mil 39 millones de dólares en la
primera mitad de 2022 eso es 80 por
ciento más que en 2021 y un 93 por
ciento más que en 2019 los turistas
registraron un gasto promedio de 700
24/7 dólares en el período de enero a
junio de este año un 39 1 por ciento más
frente a 2021 y un 34 por ciento más evo
por encima de los 540 dólares que
gastaban durante las visitas en 2019
estos visitantes dejaron más dinero a
pesar de que el número de turistas
internacionales aún está
18,4 por ciento por debajo de 2019
cuando hubo 22,6 millones de visitantes
pero el dato de este año durante los
primeros seis meses de 2022 llegaron a
mexico 10,5 millones de turistas vía
aérea en un incremento del 81 por ciento
frente al 2021 aunque los destinos
turísticos como acapulco y el caribe
mexicano persisten retos como la
violencia que ha activado alertas de
viaje sobre todo de parte de eeuu
principal origen de los visitantes y
algunas nuevas olas de ccoo y 19 sin
embargo muy buenas noticias para la
economía mexicana y finalizamos en
panamá porque anunciaron un descuento
del 30 por ciento en decenas de
medicamentos para aliviar la crisis de
precios y es una de las demandas que
hacían los ciudadanos allí en panamá
esta medida entrará en vigencia el 15 de
agosto y va a durar aproximadamente seis
meses los medicamentos beneficiados con
el descuento son para atender
enfermedades como la diabetes obesidad
hipertensión entre otros la medida fue
pactada entre el gobierno y la
farmacéutica pero la unión de
propietarios de pequeña farmacia
advirtió que por esta medida unos 850
farmacias podrían cerrar el gobierno
estableció un listado de 170
medicamentos que tendrían el 30 por
ciento de descuento a los jubilados se
les aplicará el 30 por ciento
establecido más un 20 por ciento que les
corresponde por ley muchas gracias jorge
por esta actualización a continuación en
directo américa el debate